now Tesla's chief executive Elon Musk is
in China on what's described as a high
stakes business trip the entrepreneur is
met with Chinese foreign and trade
ministers they discussed development of
electric cars and expanding Tesla's
operations China is the world's biggest
electric vehicle Market
in April Tesla announced it would build
a second Factory in Shanghai masks of
business ties to China have previously
raised concerns in Washington
let's go live now to Katrina you in
Beijing for more on this and Katrina so
Elon Musk is it's his first visit in
three years isn't it and they've really
rolled out the red carpet for him tell
us more about it
that's right so Elon Musk gets his
second day here in China uh of course
the Chinese market is enormously
important for Tesla the first plant
outside of the US is in Shanghai and
last year they produced about 70 000
cars which was about half of Tesla's
Global output but this visit high stakes
business visit also a big surprise to
the general public on Wednesday he's met
with the Commerce Minister he also met
and visited the ministry of Information
Technology and on Tuesday he met with
the head of Chinese Battery Giant catl
which also works with Tesla and he met
with China's foreign minister himself
chin Gung now we don't know much about
what has been say it's being said about
this trip uh Elon Musk is
uncharacteristically quiet on Twitter
himself there's no even not much
reporting here on Chinese social media
or state media but we have seen a
statement from the foreign Ministry in
this Farm misery statement said that
Elon Musk remarked to Chin gang that the
Chinese people were diligent and wise
and that China's achievements and
development was well deserved he also
said apparently that the economies of
the China and the US are intertwined now
this visit comes at a time when there
are questions being raised about Tesla's
expansion plans here in China so it is
no surprise that Elon Musk is seemingly
saying all the right things to very
important people here in China but is
interesting is the way that he's being
treated he's being treated almost like a
foreign dignitary himself it's notable
that Apple's Chief Tim Cook was in China
in March and he certainly didn't get the
same treatment here in China yeah
interesting I said Tesla already had one
plant in China as you say they're
talking about opening a second Factory
tell us more about why musk's ties to
China raise concerns in Washington
tensions between Washington and Beijing
just this week China rejected a meeting
between China's defense minister and the
U.S defense minister in Singapore we
also have the U.S leading this sort of
push economically for other countries
including the US of course to decouple
from Chinese Supply chains and we've had
from the Biden Administration a raft of
restrictions put on Chinese technology
companies including Huawei because of
National Security concerns and we've had
uh Tit for Tat China put a similar ban
on a U.S chip company Micron earlier
this month because of security concerns
as well so increasingly we find these
multinational companies such as Tesla
caught in these geopolitical crosshairs
and because of this we're seeing these
the leaders of these companies have to
come to China and I suppose really
maintain this balance between
maintaining good relations in Beijing as
well as in Washington interesting
Katrina thanks for that secretary you
there in Fiji